بالنسبه للمعابر بحسب وزير الخارجيه
التركي فان المعابر التي كانت مغلقه بسبب
وجود صعوبات لوجيستيه بسبب وجود اضرار على
تلك الطرق الى جانب الظروف الجويه الصعبه
باتت مفتوحه ومن الممكن نقل المساعدات
المخصصه الى سوريا عبرها وجه رساله كانت
واضحه للمجتمع الدولي بقوله بانه يجب
تيسير قدوم هذا الدعم ليدخل الى مناطق
شمال وشمال غرب سوريا
اقتراحا بفتح معابر معابر ثانيه لكي ايضا
تصل المساعدات الى مناطق في الداخل السوري
وزاره الخارجيه التركيه ليلى لاكون دقيقه
حدثت الارقام المرتبطه بالمساعدات اليوم
تتحدث عن 99 دوله الان عرضت مساعداتها على
تركيا 68 منها وصلت مساعداتها بالفعل ونحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من ثمانيه الاف اجنبي
يعملون الى جانب التركيه ومن المفترض ان
يصل المزيد من المساعدات تاخر حين يسال
المسؤولون الاتراك عن اسباب تاخر وصول
المساعدات ليس فقط الى سوريا وانما ايضا
الى مناطق ثانيه موجوده في تركيا يقولون
ان هول ما حصل حجم الكارثه الاضرار الظروف
الجويه التي لم تكن مساعده طريقه الوصول
الى تلك المناطق كلها اثرت على هذا الملف
لكن الان في الداخل التركي الطرق مفتوحه
يتم استخدام مروحيات تم استيعاب هذه
الازمه بشكل او باخر افاد من ناحيتها تقوم
بتنسيق كل هذه الامور لكن على جانب ثاني
ليله هناك بعض المعلومات الجديده التي
خرجت من افات قبل قليل بالنسبه للارقام
الهزات الارتداديه ارتفعت الى ما فوق 2000
هزاع ارتد 2000 هزاع ارتداديه تتراوح
شدتها او اشده غالبياتها بين اربعه وخمس
درجات
هنالك معلومات تتعلق بمده الزلزالين
الزلزال الاول الذي وقع فجر الاثنين بشده
7.7 استمر ل 65 ثانيه نتحدث عن اكثر من
دقيقه الزلزال الثاني الذي ضرب ناحيه
البستان ظهر يوم الاثنين بحدود الساعه
الواحده على ما اعتقد 45 ثانيه نتحدث عن
زلزالين مدتهما مجتمعان دقيقتين الا عشر
ثواني هي مده في الحقيقه طويله للغايه
بالنسبه للزلازل تقول افاد ان هذه المده
هي التي تسببت بضرر يشابه الضرر الذي يمكن
ان تحصله ان تحدثه قنابل نوويه في الارض
رئيس التقليل رئيس دائره التقليل من مخاطر
الزلازل والذي عقد مؤتمرا صحفيا هنا قبل
قليل تحدث عن وجود انهيارات في التربه
انزياحات ارضيه اكد صحه الصور التي تنقل
ان هنالك تحركت من منطقه الى اخرى
وبالتالي اشار الى مده هذين الزلزالين
دقيقتين الا عشر الا عشر ثواني وهي مده
كانت كفيله باحداث كل هذا الضرر التقارير
التي تصل الى افات تؤكد ايضا ان انطاكيا
وهي اكبر مناطق هاتاي تعرضت لضرر بالغ وقد
تكون الاولى من حيث حجم الاضرار بخصوص
انقاذ الاحياء ليلى على ما اعتقد ان هنالك
عمليه ما زالت مستمره الان تنقلها القنوات
التركيه
لفتاه اسمها اولكو
لطفل تم انقاذه بعد 128
ساعه طفل يخرج حيا الان وهناك عمليه
مستمره لفتاه اسمها اولكو حتى ان هنالك هو
اسم
يتم تداوله الان على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تركيا تنتظرك يا اولكو طفل اذا
وعمليه اخرى مستمره طفل اخر في ديار بكر
ايضا بعد 128 ساعه ونحن نامل ان يكون هذا
مصير كل العالقين حتى الان تحت الانقاض
وهذه الانباء هي التي تزيد او تكثف عمل
فرق الانقاذ التي باتت مكونه الان من اكثر
من مئه وتسعه وخمسين الف شخص تستمر
اعمالهم في تلك المناطق وذلك بعد ان انتهت
العمليات في
منطقتين
ومركز الزلزال ايضا بازارجيك قريه في
كهرمان مراش ليلى شكرا جزي